[Music]
This Is A three set When diagram The
Three sets are f t and B of students
playing FB tennis and basketball
respectively we don't need to write
Elements Inside The sets all we have to
do is understand The Different region
The concept of 3  set When diagram
Remains the same As that of a two Set
one to and this well All You Need To Do
Is visualize The Different region we
Play a simple G of coloring and guessing
we Color The region And then gu The set
Let Me Give You an  example Look at this
colored region it does not Con Any from
set t or set B So This region shows The
students Who Play Play Only FB ok What
About This region Yes it includes
students Who Play Only tennis and not FB
or
basketball What About This one  It is
Simple students Who play on basket B now
the next one Is A Very tricky Question
Look At This region Is It f intersection
b that not correct Don't worry If You
though This is the answer This Is Where
many go wrong in a three  set When
diagram This region Is f intersection b
but in the blue region We Just Marked
observe That We have included nothing
from set t So This Blue region is f
intersection b - t you should probably
get the next ones correct this region it
includes students Common  to football and
tennis but exclude basketball So It will
be f intersection t - b and what about
this Green region It will be t Inter b -
f and now for the most important region
This one Marked in Yellow This Is The
region in Which All three  sets meet or
intersect or
overlap So It is f intersection t Inter
B so These are the region you should
know well These Ones Were a b tricky so
Here Are A Few More questions to know if
you really understood The region well
Let Me draw The sets
Again  What is this region Yes This
region is F Inter t It also includes
students Who Play All three spots and
what about this dark blue region It is b
intersection
f and this Green region is t Inter B
once you know How to recognize the
region You Will  Love solving The V
diagram problems and I Would recommend
practicing The understanding of region
part well Before practicing Any
[Music]
examples